hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video ich bin
einfach mal durch die app store charts
gegangen habe dabei gesehen das auf
platz 2 34 571 keine ahnung das spiel
namens journey ist das seht ihr jetzt
hier gerade schon rechts eingeblendet
und das ist zu den blauen glaube ich
doch mal ich guck selber gar keine
deutschen youtuber deswegen weiß ich
nicht ob er das spiel habt das von ihm
ist oder ob das nur einer für ihn als
für ein geschenk gemacht hat oder so
aber wir zahlen das heute und es ist
unglaublich heiß draußen so penthin wie
die ganze zeit geheult wie ist dann
immer noch mal nicht will das spiel
spielen
hilfe was war das und wo bin ich das
fühlt sich nicht an wie mein bett und wo
ist es mode auch wer ist dann hätten wir
noch mal gelegt doch immer neben mir
verdammt was mache ich denn jetzt ohne
kuscheltier und ohne zu
da kann ich muss nichts dabei ist muss
ich gar nicht mehr soll sich zu sorgen
machen oder erst mal ausschlafen ich
würde sagen er soll erst mal ausschlafen
ich sage ja so ein spiel das ich
bestimmt kann was er machen der branche
halte aber wie mein zimmer sieht das
hier nicht geradeaus und wo sind meine
tattoos und wo sind meine beiden hobbys
film svensson jockeys endlich habe ich
mal ein labor dann schaue ich mich habe
kann ich auch laufen ein paar sekunden
später sah ich gerade durch seinen
durchsetzen hier laufe ich gehe mal eben
ist nicht wahr oder was würde ich mach
mal hier
juhu eine speichert ruhe wie cool ist
das denn was könnte ich jetzt mal tun
speichern spiel schon gespeichert das
ging ja fix haha cool
na wenigstens ist auch dieser
das schön ich meine natürlich ist das
hier wohl eine insel daher mein handy
aus der hosentasche zum glück wenig mit
klamotten eingeschlafen ist kein letzt
vielleicht habe ich auf einer höheren
ebene empfang
also ich glaube normaler mensch wird
jetzt sagen eine fühlen denn in den
höchsten berg finden aber ich würde es
mal stücken gehen wow da habe ich dann
gesagt er soll schwimmen gehen und jetzt
hat er gesagt ich muss nicht mehr
schwimmen gehen weil er schon was ist
und jetzt soll ich werk suchen wo kann
ihren berg saal die läuft doch richtig
witzig alter der läuft sowieso dieser
alten wieso glaubst du dass du doch
nichts mit findest einer natürlich
findest du den berg dann läuft's halt
nach oben in die richtung und wenn ich
wieder nach oben auf reede schon komme
ich hier weg lang und an dem weg wenn
ich den wasserlauf kommen wieder zwei
verschiedene wege läuft mal wieder nach
unten hier und dann kommt wahrscheinlich
ich glaube in dieser richtung war woher
weißt du dass du dort kein berg finden
wir es dann laufe ich halt diesmal nach
oben denn jetzt interior eine
weggabelung alles klar
ich laufe den oberen weg lang und sehr
dass ich hier nicht lang laufen kann
sonderlob für den unteren weg lang und
als wenn ihr euch fragt ob ich nicht
laufen kann der die steuerung ist echt
ein bisschen schwammig jetzt hier um die
vorkommen geheim weg
ich bin nun schon auf dem berg hier um
die kurve rum und jetzt gehen wir hier
tatsächlich wieder mit treppe hoch wieso
geht mein score unter oh mein gott wie
sowieso klatschen hier auf einmal eine
runde golf gti herum was wieso wenig
denn gestorben
ich will das noch mal probieren komme
ich dir hier hoch wie hier die seite
lang
diesmal hier die treppe hier rum jetzt
ihr lang und hier rum und hier die
trucker solchen notruf absetzen und ein
video hochladen ich setze erstmal notruf
ab ich kann meine zuschauer nicht im
stich lassen das sind zwar nur noch 2%
aqaba nach dem ablaufen des neuesten
videos kann ich immer noch den notruf
seine zuschauer gehen natürlich fort
egal was soll ich dazu sagen
12% prozent ab geflecht hatte ich doch
als erstes den notruf in sonja superuser
nicht so dass ich mir das gesagt hat
dass du das machen sollst studien wenn
bissig macht verläuft ein notrufe baden
jetzt habe ich erst mal du hast ab zum
nächsten gasthaus ich meine letztendlich
durch sich dreimal entscheidungen
treffen und jedes mal wurde dann
irgendwie von joe trotzdem die andere
entscheidung gewählt die ich eigentlich
nicht wählen wollte sondern die
entscheidung ich wählen wollte hat er
einfach nur gedacht mach ich nicht dann
guck mal da rechts das gasthaus habt die
treppe hoch und ab ins gasthaus so dass
wir dort etwas trinken können irgendwo
so nennt sich ein bekanntes gesicht was
machst du wo bin ich hier das hier ist
meine auf hashtag island hashtag island
aachener klar us kannst du mir sagen wie
ich herkam ich würde erstmal wissen wie
spät es war nicht mein video hochgeladen
habe abflugort was kann ich tun
es ist einfach so man hat immer
auswahlmöglichkeit ich dachte wow cool
ich kann entweder möglichkeit einer
möglichkeit bin eben ein bisschen heavy
rain mäßig um die story zu bestimmen
allerdings immer das was ich nehme wird
einfach abgewogen also wird einfach so
ja es ist schön dass du wissen willst
wie spät es ist mir scheißegal
an gewicht wird schon fragen was er für
mich tun kann deswegen sage ich erst mal
ich möchte etwas zu trinken
und will einfach trinken ich kann dir
einen leckeren männern check anbieten
leider habe ich nicht mehr genug bananen
magst du hinter dem haus ein paar
bananen von der ich soll meine banane
schütteln das ist das spiel
ich muss links und rechts drücken um
meine hand zu schütteln
das war das spiel
freunde an dieser stelle würde ich sagen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen ich
finde dafür das ist ein youtuber spieles
ist es also ich habe irgendwie den drang
weiter zu spielen um noch zu wissen was
du als nächstes passiert wenn ihr das
auch wissen wollt schreibst du deine
kommentare oder erlassen daumen hoch da
wenn ihr bin ich noch im zweiten teil
davon locken soll weil ich finde ich
will wissen was weiter passiert und dass
wir uns im nächsten video via
bis dahin schüttelt man schöne ballade